good morning the time being 10:00 I am
going to uh call to order the uh the
subcommittee
on uh education
training uh Etc uh of the special
committee on the family
court and um
welcome all of you here and looking out
there my guess is that I would like to
begin by calling on my good friend and
the chief of family court is that right
that's not the right title or do you
have other people you would like me to
hear from
first no it's up to you because you it's
the court that we care about and we want
you to tell
us I'm sorry someone how we got I'm
sorry someone seems to be taking offense
from what I said and so I just wanted to
make sure I stopped for a moment um I
want you to tell us what we can do for
you ter terrific terrific any way that
you want to do it just remember to turn
on the microphone and you have to speak
um as you will
know as if it's your favorite
toy
okay my name is David King I'm the
administrative judge of the New
Hampshire circuit could please follow me
yes my last name Culp k u l p is in
popcorn and your position the senior
Circuit Court
Administrator thank
you and Heather is with me this morning
mainly because she is sort of the go-to
person in the circuit court for all
things training both on the judicial
side and on the staff side so to the
extent there are questions about those
issues I would be remiss not to have
have us seated beside me so I'm not sure
how you want us to proceed Madam
chairman I'm happy to do whatever you
would like I know you sent us some
questions some I can't answer some I
probably
can't I did send you um questions I have
copies of that if anybody in the room is
not aware of what those questions were
um but um
well that's okay but um I look forward
to you proceeding as As You Wish I want
to repeat that this is not an
adversary proceeding we're not in a
court um it is truly an attempt to see
what the judicial branch sees that we
might do here to help you best meet the
needs of the citizens of the state that
is our goal our goal is
not is not to to do anything other than
that and so that's why I do I hope if
you're uncomfortable with that I can ask
you direct questions from this but um
that is why if I had my brothers I would
give you completely free reign to share
with us what you think would be helpful
okay excellent so let me just start by
sort of talking about I put the judicial
training into I'm talking just on the
judge side now sort of three buckets one
is the new judge training um since we
created the Circuit Court in 2011 since
the legislature created the Circuit
Court in 2011 we've onboarded more than
50 new judges which seems hard to
believe um but we've trained more than
50 judges since 2011 and we expect uh to
train 10 more this year which also seems
hard to believe every new judge that
comes to us comes through the governor
and counsel process as you well know we
don't pick them we don't pick their
skill set we don't pick where they come
geographically or what they bring to the
table but we uh having done this for a a
number of years with a lot of Judges
have figured out a way to try to tailor
the training and the resources that we
have to the new judges as they come on
board so if we have for example uh some
prosecutors chances are they have trial
SK s because they've been trying cases
in the Circuit Court they know the rules
of evidence they know the Cadence of a
trial but they probably know nothing
about the Family Division at all uh and
so we would tailor the training with
those new judges more heavily on family
and ligher on criminal it's more
difficult when we have sort of a
blending of talents and we have to teach
everything it's like you have to kind of
teach to the bottom of the class for all
of the new
judges we also have the issue of ongoing
training for the Circuit Court judges
that we do on a regular basis with our
own in-house resources we have five
judicial trainings a year that we put on
that are mandatory for all of our judges
um and then the third bucket is what I
call the specialty training and I the
example I use is the probate training
which is kind of a nuanced area of the
law we really haven't had appointments
to the Circuit Court with um new judges
who have had much exposure to probate at
all except for two of our staff
attorneys who went from the probate
division staff attorney position to a
Judicial position which is great and
they're both doing probate dockets now
um but again that's a sort of a really
specialized area of the lie that's where
I came from I was appointed to the
Probate Court 34 years ago this month by
Governor Greg and I'm the only probate
judge left in the state and I'm trying
to build a bench of probate judges to
come behind me um so that's a challenge
because we have to do it on an ongoing
basis so I think I'll have Heather
explain um the funding sources that we
currently have in terms of where we can
get monies where we can send judges and
um an overview of what we do in-house
for the new judge training which Heather
has put together over the last few
years and we certainly welcome questions
as we go along so please don't uh don't
let something said go unquestioned if
you have additional questions about that
um so focusing exclusively on judicial
education and funding sources that we
have available uh so thankfully we've
been able to use a few grants um at
least in part to fund some of our
judicial education programs particularly
for uh for current judges to attend
trainings uh we try to send new judges
to uh domestic violence training uh at a
national um at a national level uh when
they join the bench uh covid prevented
that from happening uh for a few years
and so thankfully using vawa funds
violence against women act funds um that
the state has allocated every year um
and a portion of that does go to the
judicial branch uh we were able to to
actually bring those trainers that we
would normally send people to uh to New
Hampshire the past year and so we were
able to provide training to the 20
judges who hadn't been able to attend
that training yet um and also include a
full day of training for uh all of our
Circuit Court judges on uh dynamics of
domestic violence including dynamics of
domestic violence as they relate to
divorce and parenting cases um and so
that was a real advantage of being able
to have some Grant funds to be able to
use for uh judicial education uh another
source of Grant funds once again the
state is allocated a portion of um
access and visitation funds every year
which are um allocated to
DHHS there's an RFP process for that
that we generally apply for Access and
visitation funds are intended to uh
provide resources to parents seeking
parenting time when there's a child
support order um so that's used in a
variety of ways um from DHHS chooses um
a variety of ways to use those funds but
one of those ways is to fund um
mediation for um Indigent parties who
have um parenting matters and also a
child support order or are seeking to
create a child support order uh so we're
able to fund some mediation training
both for mediators but also uh some
training for um for judges and for court
staff around skills related to
facilitating parenting plans
facilitating the creation or U
maintenance of child support orders um
from that fund this year we were able to
use some of those funds to create some
videos that will be forthcoming and
thanks uh to this committee who made
recommendations I think in in a former
um iteration of this committee made some
recommendations that we include more
videos on our website particularly for
parenting issues so we did uh create uh
a video about how to um how to create
parenting plans and how to create uh
child support uh how to complete a child
support form so we're able to use those
funds for training but also for ongoing
train training for judges um but also
ongoing training for some of our staff
and mediators I'm getting a bit of field
into the staff bucket but um but I think
it's helpful to note how we use those
funds thank you is is that training um
or are those videos available to the
public also or is it focused
on on the court staff they're not yet
currently available to the public but
they will be yes they were they were
intended to be created for the public
often the staff will use those for their
own education and also use those with
members of the public with whom they
meet um our staff are often meeting with
self-represented litigants to assist
them with those forms so it's a great
training tool for for both staff and
litig against representative
Pearson thank you Madame chairman and uh
thank you counselor um unless I've cut
you off in your presentation I'm not
hearing any money is coming from the
general budget to the judicial system
it's grants and it's sliding over from
DHHS since I'm already anticipating
talking about the next budget for the
Judiciary uh this will be helpful so I
can I can talk about that in general
terms and um we have always had an
education line in our budget going back
to I want to say maybe 2007 when um the
chair of house finance is now in this
room um our and we were in the Lynch
sort of Leaning years the we cut our
education line dramatically uh I think
it's now around $90,000 which covers
education for all three levels of court
there's a separate amount for it folks
um under Supreme Court rule
45 that in theory is managed by what we
used to call jck the judicial branch
education committee it was chaired by uh
justice Convoy for a number of years I
was on it for probably a dozen years
that's kind of Gone by the wayside but
the M the line item is still there and
and Aaron may have some more specifics
about how it can be spent but we can up
we can ask to spend that money as can
the superior court and the Supreme Court
there's no specific allocation anymore
about x amount for each court but there
are some general funds available for
judicial
education um in that fun in in that line
item your honor it's possible that your
colleague has something to add to
that oh good I answer excellent I'll
give her the
chair
Hello nice to see a few of you twice in
a row um Diane Martin uh director of the
administrative office of the courts the
Chief Justice asked me to come over in
case you had questions about the general
fund budget or specifics around amount
spent and that kind of thing so I have
that sounds like you're interested in it
um judge king has been here forever and
obviously has a lot of knowledge about
the history and he was really close to
the exact number which is uh
94,500 is the total amount for General
training in the courts it's it's used
for all employees we have about 800 and
judges um and as you heard from um
senior administrator kulp and judge king
there are other sources of funds for
training those are generally grants um
and so I have ballpark numbers on that
as well but 94 to hand out to us I don't
I actually just got the grants unit to
give me a report aspir it this morning
after the chief asked me to head over
with that information so I can give you
the numbers that I have but
94,500 divided between AOC Circuit Court
Superior Court Supreme to do all of the
training that's generally funded in
other words not much not much I did the
number it was about $118 per employee
and some of the judge training for for
example Superior Court sends new judges
to a trending in Nevada that the cost
for that has gone up because travel and
all of that is more expensive now so the
average is about $66,000 per judge so if
we send six judges that's $36,000 right
there um in addition to that as judge
king was just saying there's another
bucket that is
ecort um specific and that is used for
all parts of the judicial branch to go
trainings related to that and so folks
from Circuit Court Superior AOC it
people go to a training that's usually
annual related to ecourt and so that's
where those funds generally go and then
drug court has a separate allocation
that the legislature that is
specifically requested for that it's not
actually generally used for our
employees except for those directly
involved it's more used for the um drug
court themselves the people who run
those drug courts to get training to do
that well so they're not necessarily our
employees they are people that we
contract
with is that report something that you
would be willing to share with us I can
get you the num she's she's literally
putting it together but the totals so
there's what you have there isn't
something that you can share no this is
just I I pulled my because I could
quickly do this myself the
Appropriations that we have and how
they're divided I was going to ask
I can give you this though yeah if you
could that would be great I was actually
going to see if
representative Pearson might be willing
to walk down the hall to the finance
office and get copies for us I might if
I ask
nicely that is so kind of you I
appreciate it and I know also that close
family members appreciate it
too he's been like a son to me
for just you know okay thank you so much
what that will tell you really is how
the legislature has what they've given
us in total and how it's divided um
without without much other detail the
quick numbers I got were so far this
year from the general fund about
31,000 has been expended that's not
necessarily from this appropriation it's
it's probably across over between the
two but since the start of the fiscal
year um and then from Grants including
and you have to understand this includes
conferences and trainings and trainers
coming into us something along the lines
of 85,000 in FY
23 for just Court thank you for taking
the time to pull that up for us it's
very helpful you are welcome so anybody
else have any questions about that could
we go back to my old friend
okay that's twice has been an agist
reference um uh are you anticipating
with great Delight a bill that we may
pass and the governor might sign that
extends the age from 70 to 75 am I
anticipating it
yeah you don't have to answer that
question it's not relevant to the
subject and old refers not to the judges
or my age I would lose in that it refers
to the fact that we have worked together
on these issues for 20 years or more oh
wait a minute more than 20 years so
that's what the old refers to is that
fair that's fair okay the judge doesn't
the judge doesn't want to overrule that
no okay go on say that it was 40 years
ago that I was a member of the
legislature either because that seems
like an awful long time
ago and by the way I also worked with
the judge's father
quite happily I'll shut my mic
off uh so that's great uh Diane's giv us
a sort of a breakdown of the general
funds I also understand Aaron explained
to me this morning that there's a bill
that would provide for a trainer and
that all sounds great too um I think in
terms of training the Circuit Court
judges there is always a benefit to
sending judges to these Out ofate
programs there're
they're excellent I've never gone to an
out of state program where I didn't come
back um feeling energized and Having
learned a lot but our focus on the new
judges really has to be on substantive
law for New Hampshire because the
circuit court is a court of limited
jurisdiction we have only the
jurisdiction that you give us but it's
huge now I I say the superior court has
civil cases in criminal cases we have
civil cases and criminal cases but then
we have landlord tenant we have abuse
neglect we have Guardianship and all
these cases case types that have nuanced
legal issues that we really have to
train on and because we have 34
locations around the state and most of
them are what I would consider to be
small courts we don't have judges who
can be Specialists the judges really
have to be able to do pretty much
everything with the exception of with
the exception of probate um we've cut
that off to just a few judges um only in
the Nashua Manchester Maybe be conquered
can we have judges who are doing
primarily one case type because the
dockets are large enough for that and
there aren't many judges that have the
appetite to do only family even if they
come on the bench thinking all I want to
do is family it doesn't take long to
burn them out to the point where they
ask to get a criminal docket once in a
while too so I think we do as good a job
as we can do with the in-house resources
that we have on our judicial training as
I said we've trained over 50 judges it's
a six week basic curriculum that
involves some self-study it involves I
use the word classroom but it's you know
a conference room linking up with senior
judges uh doing Court
observation at the end of the six weeks
we need to cut them loose and get them
on the bench to start hearing cases and
that's kind of what we do and then we
have a lot of tools that I've explained
to this committee before that that are
ongoing that judges can use um as
resources I we have also talked I think
uh in this committee
about and I know Madam chairman you were
on the judicial the judicial performance
evaluation committee with me and with
Justice Convoy for seemed like a long
time and one of the things we talked
about was the judicial evaluation
process to include maybe a retired judge
who goes and observes judges in the
courtroom sort of mentors new judges I
would love to be able to put something
like that together the difficulty that
we have is we have currently
14 judges who are over the age of 70 who
are willing to work and they all have
full dockets as as full of docket as
they can take because we need them right
now so as we continue to build the
judicial resources and and add judges
hopefully some of those more senior
judges who still have a lot of good
years in them could be used in other
ways that don't require their orders to
be co-signed for example um and I I
think there's a a place for that in the
sort of ongoing judicial education if
you will but I think Heather can maybe
give you just a an overview of what the
six weeks consists of so you have a
sense of what we try to do with our
brand new judges who are coming in from
practice if that would be
helpful
so for us the first week is really about
orienting the judges to the role of
being a judge uh we know the transition
between being a lawyer in practice
sometimes not uh specifically in
practice but in some other role that
uses their legal skills to being a judge
is is a fairly large leap um and so we
focused that first week really on the
role of a judge orienting them to
Circuit Court orienting them to uh other
tasks that that they'll be taking on
um as well as the communities that they
serve uh so we currently do work with
them around trauma implicit bias um uh
ethics judge king spends about a half a
day uh on judicial ethics with them as
well um mental health uh Ada access
language access so areas that are not
substantive areas of law but areas that
they really need need to know as a
framework for the rest of the work that
they'll be doing in the Circuit Court um
we have about two weeks of full of
um what I would consider Family Division
training so about one of those weeks is
divorce parenting and minor
guardianship we do about two days of
domestic violence and
stalking and about 4 days of abuse and
neglect and other juvenile matters
so termination of parental rights uh
juvenile delinquency chins Etc so a
little over onethird of the training is
related to Family Division cases
specifically um and then the the rest of
the weeks are related to our other case
types that they'll be
handling we really try to weave
different um pedagogical methods into
that into that training um so it's not
just sitting in a classroom when
listening to someone lecture uh we have
um Preparatory work that they do um
observational work that they do um
working with the expert judges um as
well as with uh staff attorneys Court
administrators our DB program manager
our uh ecourt specialist so we weave
many staff into that training as well as
judges um and external presenters as
well
and we do it at no cost essentially um I
think we have had Nami come in and with
some lived experience folks and we've
given a small stien to them um but other
than that it's inhouse it's taking
experienced judges Off the Bench out of
dockets to come in and do the training
or using as Heather said our staff
attorneys our in-house
resources
um but but let me just
question when you say at no
cost isn't it really of some cost
because my understanding is there's no
real free time that you're try trying to
fill that by staff and and judges doing
this they're not doing other things that
they're responsible for valid point I
mean is it there I guess in economics
would be the opportunity cost right we
the cost of taking a judge Off the Bench
and cancelling a docket for a day to
bring a judge lamir in to do the marital
training is a day of marital cases that
aren't getting hurt in Brentwood when we
bring the criminal judges in it's the
same thing um so yes for sure using our
inhouse
resources um is taking judges Off the
Bench and and causing delays in getting
cases heard and orders out that's and at
the same time when we do our five
trainings a year that are mandatory for
judges that's a day pretty much that
we're not doing hearings we have to do
all the emergencies that day we have
various ways of dealing with that
typically we have an arraignment judge
or two that skips the training and stays
behind hopefully a retired judge that's
what we try to find a retired judge
that's under 70 that can do the
arraignments without co-signing uh
but the judges bring their laptops and
the clerks are instructed at you know
certain breaks in the day the DVS the
EXP party maritals the stocking
petitions that have to be ruled on you
know pretty much in real time we have to
deal with those so it's it's not a
seamless um day where we have training
every single minute but it's that's how
we've managed to to get those five days
in thank you I I I have heard from you
and observed
the Court's efforts to use um modern
technology for me modern technology is
giving of the advocus but um you know
really modern technology in hopes that
that might uh be time and cost
efficient and some of that
involves having uh the
potential um I'm going to use the word
plaintiff since I'm a non-lawyer or I
can use it in a very very general sense
but I think you know what I mean um who
the citizen who comes in and sees the
machine and has no idea about how to use
that machine and also staff that has to
then
help the people you so do you have
specific training as you begin to um
include in your
Arsenal um
uh Information Technology tools to help
both the
citizen and the court professional know
how to use those tools so if I I'm not
sure I understand the question but one
of the oh that's because it was not
stated clearly but that's okay it's
because I
didn't grasp it but one of the
challenges for sure with
self-represented litigants is navigating
the e-filed cases that we have the
electronic filed cases and when we when
we went down that route in 2013 with
small
claims we thought it was going to make
things easier and take less staff and
what we've learned over time is it's
more complicated for some folks and it
definitely takes at least as much time
on the staff end staff spend a lot of
time our information center spends a lot
of time with folks information center
that we started in 2013 just
by way of a a quick fact they took their
five million millionth call this summer
which I'm pretty proud of um they take
about 500,000 calls a
year yeah closer to 400,000 a little
over 400,000 uh so we have some uh Court
Navigators we have two court Navigators
which are individuals who are trained to
work with self-representative folks in
the lobbies of cour houses to help them
navigate whatever they legal problem is
the bulk of those uh are ironically
probate related issues because the
probate process is also an electronic
filed process now and is not intuitive
for self-representative folks who are
trying to uh navigate the probate
process having lost a loved one um
that's something that we are certainly
hoping to expand over
time the the electronic tool is great in
terms terms of eliminating the paper but
it's a process on our end um question to
that no could we just wait one moment
please my colleague has a question yes
thank you madam chair and thank you uh
judge uh what if let's say here's a
hypothetical a prosay person comes and
freaks out at the machine does that
person have the right to say can I
bypass that and do it the oldfashioned
way absolutely there's a there is an
exception uh request for exception for
electronic filing that I've never denied
one of those we have a lot of people who
don't have computers who aren't computer
literate who just want to file in paper
that's absolutely fine they file in
paper we scan it in and and rather than
send their Court notices and orders
electronically we send them by first
class mail um the oldfashioned way thank
you
you with your permission I'd like to
just add a a little more information
about the other resources and these are
new um so we did receive from the um
governor's office and and the
legislature approved arpa funds to be
used for Access um and so our office of
access and Community engagement which
applies to the whole branch has six
projects that are arpa funded which
address some of the issues that you're
raising and so I didn't want to not
mention them we're going to one of them
and I'm not the expert I wish that our
Deputy was here she could tell you all
the details but one of them is community
Navigators which will train um a number
of people to be available to help pray
litigant um there are two projects that
I think would be of interest to you the
other one is similarly going to have a
number of people trained who'll be
available not only um on site but also
remotely and available to go out into
the community and support people in
filing obviously in a safe public place
but those are projects that are
commencing now we've done rfps have
vendors to work with them and so our
goal is to provide better access to
Justice through some of those
projects you thank you very much and
does that apply to well I wasn't going
to say not I imagine not to The Supremes
but to the other courts Superior and
circuit I mean technically it will apply
to all of them including Supreme so if
you had a litigant who was doing a pro
sayfe f and needed assistance they would
be they will be available to all
litigant um but are focused on proa
litigant and I think circuit court is
the most likely um Court to have those
and the people who are most in
need and that is
a that recognition of that is something
that that the Chief Justice shares
absolutely great thank
you
another question from chairman Pearson
thank you uh Madam chair and thank you
your honor and
counselor um I was a volunteer fire
firefighter um I have a son who's a fire
lieutenant in
Manchester and so I have been uh well
educated in PTSD issues I recently had a
conversation with the Chief Justice on
this that given many of the people who
appeared during the 14 hours the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit Court took public testimony
there were uh statements of judicial
bias
and uh E I know from my
experiences that even if one is not
intentionally leaning one way life
circumstances May tilt one a certain way
one of my day jobs is part-time CEO of a
medical facility and I Shadow the new
hires because the 9:00 appointment just
happens to have a disease that killed
this new gal's grandmother and then the
930 appointment was something that her
husband worries about and by the end of
the day she's seen loved ones in the
persons of several people and what is
she going to do this new hire she's
either going to become cold and
professional as a defense
mechanism or go home and cry or drink or
both and yet tomorrow we start a new day
and so I have been able to
debrief the new hires as to what did you
feel when you saw and the conversation I
was honored to have with the Chief
Justice was if you are in family court
and you hear all of these things day by
day by day and and just every so often
one of those cases triggers something in
you of an experience or in a loved one
what are you going to do with that and
it would be something um because I know
of his interest in mental health court
issues that could be uh explored in
ongoing training especially in Family
Court uh how is the cumulative effect of
being on the bench and family court for
week upon week um impacting you perhaps
in ways you're not aware of that would
be just a pitch for further
exploration and I would add to that that
it's not just the judges it's the staff
um because they're dealing with these
folks at the at the window and they're
typing in the dictation Center the
judge's orders and I have had staff
members come to me in tears um you know
the judges follow a family in an abuse
neglect case that has maybe an opioid
issue and the judge thinks things are
going in the right direction they're
they've been clean for a while and all
of a sudden you know a judge called me
on a Sunday night and somebody that they
thought was was better overdoses and
dies and the judge is blaming himself
and the staff person who typed that
order has been following this family
because they've been typing the orders
and now they're typing the order where
the person's overdosed and it's taking a
toll on them too so my apologies to the
staff I wish to include them yes very
much yeah so I mean we we can we clearly
can do a better job we have done
trainings around that for both judges
and staffs but we we always can do a
better a better job providing those
resources and the chief has been very
supportive we have a mental health
person in the AOC now who's great uh
who's a resource for staff and judges
when we have these kinds of issues come
up so U but it's a real issue thank you
for
that and we do include a new judge
orientation and fairly regularly
connections to resources to um to
support judges uh around that issue
including the employee assistance
program which I know this legislature
has continued to support and has been an
incredible resource for us um and so
that's a a resource that we continue to
refer both judges and staff
to and do you have any way of knowing if
they take advantage of those
resources so the mental health and
wellness coordinator has done some
tracking around that um we know because
of our our own personal referrals of
staff and judges to that that it is
utilized um and and utiliz both
individually and collectively um some of
the trauma experienced is collective uh
in a court where all the staff and
judges are are handling the same issues
um and so uh EAP has been gracious to be
able to come in and support a full a
full panoply of an office or Department
uh that's dealing with an issue but
there's all always more we can do do and
always more resources uh that we can
provide our
folks thank
you what
else I think I touched on this earlier
but and it has come up in previous um
meetings before this committee but in
terms of the perception that judges
aren't writing thorough orders or it's
taking a long long time to get orders
out I just remind the um committee that
the Circuit Court does not have law
Clerks we have three staff attorneys for
61 or 62 judicial officers which uh
doesn't go as far as we would like um we
tend to use the staff attorneys
um in the more complex cases there's a
staff attorney who uh assists judge
lamir in some of the complex marital
cases I have a three-day trial next week
in the a trust case that has 10 lawyers
I'm going to bring a staff attorney with
me for that trial because it involves a
novel issue that the Supreme Court
recently looked at that is probably a
fair chance this case will go up but
that's one case out of a huge number of
cases and um that's one area where I
think um both in terms of the the
quality of writing because you all
visited courts and you can see the pace
of the hearings during the day and each
of those cases required the judge to
write an order at some point without
assistance if there were more more of
those types of resources I think the
orders would be U perhaps more thorough
and would get out more timely that's
just a
suggestion yes thank you madam chairman
thank you your honor thank you Council
um I recall early on when the special
committee got going reference was made
to a recent report that analyzed need
not on the basis of numbers of cases but
on the amount of time spent which is
probably a better metric could I or we
have a copy of that because uh while
last time I followed you after you made
a great pitch for the budget I came in
after that I want to get in there first
and make my pitch for next time and I've
already got lock clerks on my list uh
could we or I at least have a copy of
that report so just I want to make sure
I know what you're asking about you're
talking about the weighted case study
that we had done by the national yes of
course we can get you that would you
like it electronically or would you like
a paper copy we can get copies for the
whole committee if oh I like paper but I
can't speak for anybody who
is active in this
Century of course representative Koto
thank you thank you madam chairwoman I I
would appreciate an electronic one just
so if we need to email it or or shareed
if especially if we're going to be
trying to make pitches we might have to
email it to uh other Representatives if
that's possible what we'll do both thank
you what that will demonstrate is a
couple of things it was done both on the
judge side of the operation and the
staff side both in Superior Court and
and circuit court I think the number of
full-time equivalent judges that are
required under the weighted case load is
67 point something um today I think
we're at 43 full-time judges and then we
as I said we use 14 judges over the age
of 70 we have still have three part-time
judges and we have three senior active
judges so is that counting the new seven
or not that's not counting the new seven
that's on the bench today okay thank you
uh we have four judges that will be
funded as of July 1 uh and I'm hope
hopeful that the governor will fill
those um we have two that have been
confirmed that are awaiting their start
date one that's been nominated that gets
us to the 45 number which is where we
would be right now we'll be at 49 with
the July 1st judges but we also have
several retirements this year so it's
kind of a revolving door which is why
this training is so
important yes thank you for letting me
take question thank you for taking my
question um the four new judges that are
for for July 1st which type of judges
are
those whatever Governor sonunu gives us
but was it like allocated for C was were
they allocated for like Family Division
or no the I mean that since July 1st
2011 all judges have just been appointed
to the Circuit Court which has three
divisions the statute presumes that
those judges will be competent in all
three divisions of the Court um and as I
said perhaps before you came in
representative cutab we we would love to
have judges who are Specialists but
because most of our 34 locations are
fairly small courts it just doesn't work
that way and unless you're in a nsha or
a Manchester or maybe conquered it's
hard to have judges who do only one case
type because they have to basically keep
the dockets moving so what we hope is we
get judges with trial experience because
that's the most important thing and then
um Family Division experts would be
great because that's the steepest
learning curve we've got former
prosecutors who are doing a great job in
the Family Division but it just took
them a long time to get there
um it's easier to teach the criminal
side of the operation because it's you
know there's just not as many moving
Parts very of glance I just wanted to
make a comment just to say that I think
it's great that you're going the um new
judges coming in would be uh well-versed
for all courts because I I think that's
important because what I was hearing uh
when I made my visit to concer is that a
lot of times um you know when there's an
absente you know somebody has is out for
illness um you have to be able to have
some flexibility I'm a nurse so I know
about um how important it is to be
flexible so I think it's uh it's great
to hear that that's what's going on so
and I think in your industry they call
it triaging right that's what we
basically do every day in the coin
system and that's a great example
because I can get a call on a Sunday
night that a judge is going to be out
the next day there's a docket there's a
a lot of people that are signed up to be
in that Court to have their case heard
on Monday morning and we scramble to try
to shuffle judges around maybe we can
find a judge to cover the morning a
different judge to cover the afternoon
but we have to those cases have to be
heard so we don't have any we don't have
an injured reserve list where we can
call a judge and say Hey you know a
retired judge and say can you go to
Franklin tomorrow CU that judge is
already booked somewhere else so I'm
hoping we will get to the point where we
get closer to that you know weighty case
load number where we'll have more
flexibility I wonder if Bel chick's
available now he might have some free
time and I'm sure he's going to
Cincinnati OH is he yeah oh I didn't
know I'm sorry
um if you don't if you have anything
else that you want to say about training
that's great I'd like to hear everything
you have I also do want to go to uh
another onew title and that's
accountability and it might not be a
word that fits
precisely I mean it might be a you know
a round Peg that has to go into a square
hole or vice versa
but the basic question is
is there a
process that can hold short of
charging a judge with inappropriate
behavior in whatever way um where we can
assess in some way the accountability of
the judge where someone is observing
what is going on in the courtroom where
someone is particularly sensitive to
concerns that might have arisen and a
process um for addressing the issue
which might
include additional targeted training or
consultancy in some way great great
question I'll I'll start with the
statutory requirement that every judge
is evaluated every three years through a
formal process and again that goes back
to the judicial performance evaluation
committee that we served on together and
we had Professor Smith from unh work
with us to refine the instrument that we
use to do those evaluations I have I
think 13 evaluations on my desk from the
most recent round that I need to review
uh and then review with the judicial
officers so that's sort of the first
line that we have to do and it's a good
tool um but I've been doing this for a
while and I have often said that rarely
am I surprised when I get a judge's
evaluation because it's a small state
lawyer don't hesitate to speak up when
they see an issue we certainly get
plenty of complaints from
self-represented
litigant uh and it's very easy for me as
the administrative judge if there's a
complaint about a judge you know the
judge
did you know pick the atrocity swore at
me something happened in a hearing
typically within 30 minutes I can have
the audio from a hearing on my laptop
and I can listen to it and I do that
regularly and if there's an issue I
always pick up the phone and have a chat
with the judge more often than not it I
don't agree with the complaint that was
made because it's goes more to the
merits of the case but that's an ongoing
process I mentioned earlier I think it
would be a great tool for us to
have probably I'm picking this term out
of the air but a court Observer who
would be a retired judge with experience
who could sit in a courtroom observe a
new judge or a judge who might have
issues and spend time with that judge
whether it's a demeanor issue whether
it's a timing list getting on the bench
whether it's issues with written orders
to sort of be a a mentor that we could
have two or three of those
available on an ongoing basis I think
would be a wonderful tool again we're
limited retired judges are limited to
the number of Judge number of days that
they can work by Statute um there's a I
think it's RS say 493 chapter 493 a
retired judge is limited um by that
Statute in the number of days they're
available to work and most of those
judges max out it's about 80 days a year
that they can work if that restriction
were limit lifted or changed we might be
able to pick up some judge
days of even if it was specifically
targeted um to something like this that
in addition to sitting X number of days
they could be a court Observer um that
would be a wonderful tool for me as an
administrative judge to have to say you
know we've got an issue down in
Nashua um judge Bole Judge Jerry Bole
who's R been retired for a few years but
still loves to work could you go to
nashille and sit with judge X for a
couple of days and and give some
positive feedback and and report back to
me and that I I think that would be
great is that something that uh a
retired
experienced attorney could
do sure I think that would be a
possibility I think the Judge who's been
on the other side of the bench which is
really a different world is probably
better situated to do it but I mean it
could be a lay person that you know if
it's something that's
obvious but I think in terms of
mentoring judges retired judges are
probably the best resource that we could
come up with and um I gathered that the
hour of restriction has to do with
compensation more than anything else
correct I recall when the legislation
went through there was a concern that at
the time there were a number of retired
judges and I think the concern concern
maybe legitimately of the the
legislature was you only need this many
judges you you're already your bench is
full and if we take the governor off
this you'll be you'll have way more
judges than you reasonably need to move
the cases and it's going to cost a lot
of money that's not the reality for us
we don't have anywhere near enough
judges according to the weighted case
load and that's one of the limitations
that we have is that statute it only
costs the state the pum for the judge
there's no benefits obviously because
they're retired
um just something to think about and in
terms
of maybe it's not related here but in
terms of this case load problem
generally
speaking um if you had your choice and
you won't have your choice we know that
but if you had your
choice and you were told that you could
bring in a certain number of
bodies would you choose in the next
bium to
have more judges or would you choose to
have more support
staff that's a light and frothy question
yeah that's a great question why do
people say it's a great question when
it's a question that you don't want to
answer because I'm I'm trying to think
how I'm going to answer I'm just trying
to say something and to fill the void
um I'm going to say a blend would be my
choice maybe how how judicious of you a
couple of judges and maybe three staff
attorneys to support the bench would be
and I'm trying to be conservative in my
number I'm not and the chief has been
great about adding judges but I think we
all agree we can't do it all at once we
have to do it in increments um
um I guess my my question which shows
how little I know and why I'm sitting
here and you're sitting there is that I
would think that one of the
most effective
changes you could
Advocate would be for judges to have
clerks now this is something of course
that The Supremes are um protected from
and the Superior Court judges are
protected from but if in the Circuit
Court the judge didn't have to do all
the work that is usually the
responsibility of the judge but also the
work that is usually in other court
situations the
responsibility of support staff
would that not make a significant change
in the ability to manage cases and both
in terms of the number and in terms of
the stress in yesterday's hearing at
some point someone objected to the fact
that judges might have to work in the
evening or weekends and truthfully I
have no sympathy for that argument
judges are not hired to work a a 40h
hour week I guess it's Now 37 and a half
hour week week it's a professional job
and you're not hired by the hour so I
have no problem with judges agreeing to
be judges and then finding they have to
work when they might otherwise want to
watch um was it Cincinnati did you say
where belich going that's where he's
going yeah he said so okay um no
sympathy for that at all but I do have
sympathy for a judge wanting to do the
best job of a judge and being hampered
by also having to do work that is
difficult and complex I'm not demeaning
it in any way but that could equally if
not better be done by someone who's a
trained
clerk I think that would be a huge
resource and I think if my colleagues
especially those that sit in the Family
Division were here they would
say we call them staff attorneys but
that resource to assist with writing the
difficult cases doing the legal research
and I agree with you madam chairman we
tell new judges this is not a 9-to-5 job
this is the circuit Court's open 247 365
days a year we our judges take calls in
the middle of the night for domestic
violence issues search warrants
placement of
children you can be on vacation in
Florida if you have a cell phone you may
get a call from someone and you you have
to deal with it that's just the nature
of the Beast so I I it's never been a
9-to-5 job it's never been touted
deception and if a judge thinks that's
going to be the case they shouldn't
apply thank you uh chairman Pearson yes
thank you um I face the same thing with
my doctors uh I think you know uh judge
king I've studied the Rules of Evidence
extensively and my Amendment which
replaced the entire bill of either 475
or 499 states that if a judge refuses to
accept a proferred piece of evidence
over the objection of a litigant or if a
judge accept a profit piece of evidence
over the objection of the other litigant
the judge because of course they did it
for very good reasons their ruling must
state that in writing is that something
the review of that new line on the form
saying this is why the judge ruled that
way is that something that could be
reviewed by someone with and I don't
mean to disrespect but lesser
training so to find
patterns if if that bill requires a
written ruling on every objection I'm
going to use the trial I'm going to have
next week I'm G to have 10 lawyers in a
courtroom do you know how many
objections I'm going to have to rule on
in the course of three days with 10
lawyers in a courtroom if I have to make
a written finding on every one of those
objections that's going to be a 30-day
trial not a three-day trial
so that's what the Supreme Court is for
if there's an objection judges are
trained to rule on the records it's
overruled you know judge Perkins who I
love dearly I tried dozens of cases in
front of him in the superior court jury
trials bench
trials he would say he would say
objection he would say one word he he
didn't want to hear an argument you
would say
leading uh argumentative whatever it was
and he would rule up or down it would be
on the record and the Supreme Court
could review that that's what my
amendment was seeking to do not just say
no I'm not going to accept that or yes I
am even though you don't want me to uh
here's why in a in a word or two and
that will be written because a lot of
our testimony was the judge refused to
accept that piece of evidence and didn't
say why or the judge accepted it and I
objected as as a prosay litigant and the
judge didn't say why and I think the fix
is in and I tried to maintain that
judges don't do that judges do it for a
reason and so the fallback was okay can
it be written in the
record yeah and if it's going to be
written and we have to do that it's just
going to it will dramatically slow down
the pace of a trial it pass unanimously
in the house so be prepared
okay and and when I say dramatically I
mean again there are in the course of a
trial lots of objections and I don't
know if the if we take take a recess
issue a written order come back I would
expect that's how judges would want to
do it so they don't lose track of them I
think the tenor of the amendment became
the bill which was passed by Voice vote
was very simply a word um I offer this
piece of evidence it is not accepted
because it is non-probative or whatever
it's that's quick it's not a long
dissertation it's one or two words and
that now is in the record one word two
words and I think what I was Lo what was
lost on me with in the record me when we
when judges and lawyers think about the
record record we think about the record
of the hearing so it's it's the
objection is overruled it's it's
irrelevant it's okay that should I mean
litigants have the right to understand
why you let something or in or didn't
let it in that should be clear at the
time on the record to the litigant and
that's all the amendment become Bill is
asking for because it will speak to many
who were in those 14 hours of testimony
that no answer was given I can't say
whether no answer was given or not I
wasn't there but I'm going to assume the
judge did it for a reason and this
simply says tell us the reason and if a
lot of Judges have told the reason this
will not impact very much except it will
give us an answer to those who don't
like what judges do yeah well I'm
certainly in favor of Judges making it C
on the record why they have either kept
something out or let something in okay
and usually the lawyers make the
argument I mean the objection leading
sustained the record's clear why that
question wasn't allowed but as we know
in family court prosay is what 80% yes
85 and they may not give a reason they
just say something right yeah that's the
challenge of training new judges about
how to deal with self-represented
litigant which is a large part of our
training and cedal fairness sure with
all du respect that bill is not before
this committee could we no it isn't but
the subject is in terms of
review in terms of what they
need should this become
law that's why I brought it up okay go
on if you've read the amendment become
the bill or if you would I'd be happy to
talk with you about it before it go to
the Senate okay because there may be a
way I can improve it when it goes to the
Senate by making a suggestion as the
chief sponsor okay thank you sounds good
thank
you anything
else if I may add um going back just a
beat to uh judge King's offering of of
the blend I think is the word you used
uh whenever we think about adding new
judges we think about making sure that
there's sufficient Staffing to support
those judges so in addition to staff
attorneys to work with the judges on
orders Etc making sure that our courts
are staff sufficiently to be able to get
those orders out and process those cases
Etc so uh we've been incredibly grateful
for the positions that the legislature
has given us I think whenever we're
we're adding new judges we just want to
think about um the ratio of of Judge to
staff that would make the most sense for
the weighted case load to be able to
make sure that those orders are getting
out timely that's the other piece of the
equation related to timely orders and
handling of cases well thank you for
saying that and I think that's a very
good goal but I think what we're dealing
with here is recognition that as
admirable as the goal is um we um have
not attained that goal of having enough
you use the word staff attorneys and so
I'll use that because I want to be more
appropriate I was using a more general
term um
um we have seen that as a
problem and perhaps we're wrong perhaps
having additional staff
attorneys um to begin to mirror what
goes on in the other courts um is not a
desirable goal but I at this point from
our position we think that you need new
more Clerk
more staff attorneys to do what needs to
be done and if we're wrong if you
believe that the ratio that you have now
is more than adequate and the cases
would not move um more uh more
efficiently uh and more
appropriately um if we added more staff
attorneys then tell us that we're we're
wrong because you're the experts and and
um and we respect that but what we
observe and what we have
heard truthfully
from employees of the court
system who needless to say do not want
to be
named um and understandably so um is
that the
workload for staff attorneys is such
that it interferes with the smooth
operation of the
Court yes and so um so perhaps I I'm
using terminology in a particular way so
maybe I can just articulate that and
then and of course we would welcome
whatever resources the legislature would
be willing to provide when we say staff
attorney there's a particular position
of Staff attorney that um supports
judges in doing that legal re research
preparing some portions of briefs Etc um
those folks are Central and then
allocated to judges as there may be need
um based on what the what judges around
the state are handling uh so we
currently have three of those our
weighted case load indicates we need
more of those um I think you've
mentioned law clerks which are generally
assigned to a particular judge that's
the model in Supreme and Superior Court
um so that's a law cl to a judge or
perhaps a law clerk to two judges so
that's a more concentrated resource that
may do many of the things that our staff
attorney does but does it for a smaller
subset of Judges um clerks in our in our
system are the the court staff who in
Circuit Court um are not required to be
attorneys uh those clerks manage the
courts themselves um and so they manage
both the staff but also the schedules
for judges um resource allocation within
a court location or sometimes more than
one Court location depending on that
management group and then uh I've been
using the term Court staff to apply to
all of the staff that work in the courts
doing the case processing themselves uh
so those folks are not assisting the
judges in terms of writing orders or
doing that legal research but doing the
case processing that happens on the
front end and the back end before a
judge receives the case and after a
judge is completed with the case um so
those are those are the four sort of
buckets that we've been talking about I
know this committee previously has
mentioned Court monitors as well um
which in Superior Court are Court staff
that sit with the judge in the courtroom
and handle the record um and keep track
of evidence that may be coming in ETC um
but that's those are distinctions in
court staff um based on role and
title I I I thank you for that and I um
I very much appre appreciate it and I do
hope that you will understand that not
one of us well maybe most of us sitting
here do not
presume to know everything we should
know about how the court operates so
perhaps we are using terms that a Layman
might use that would mean something very
different to you I think a couple of
times I've tried to use the very general
term of
support um leaving it not to me or to my
colleagues in the legislature but to you
to figure
out where that support is needed um so
please understand that whether I say
staff attorney or Clerk or whatever
else my concern and I believe the
concern of my colleagues and I haven't
heard them disagree is that there seems
to
be a problem despite all your Goodwill
and despite all your willingness to be
appreciative of
whatever the legislature chooses to give
to the courts uh that
nonetheless you as professionals with
high
standards could do a better job at what
you're trying to do if you had the
necessary I don't the
necessary you know we're not talking
about building an indoor swimming pool
for you here um the necessary support
and
that's
where we want you to know that we are
concerned we don't want to make your
decisions for you we need your guidance
um we recognize the value of three
independent branches we're oldfashioned
enough to believe in that we you know we
don't we're not over we don't want to
overstep from the legislative to the
judicial but we think that we have
enough
evidence that may or may not stand up in
the court of law but does stand up in
the legislative branch that you need
additional help to do what we expect you
to do and we can say well we think you
should have more X Y or Z but you can
tell us what you do need and to
hesitate is to really do a disservice to
your branch because without telling us
our we can't we could only guess and why
should we guess and give you the wrong
supports when you know what we need and
it might be that you have procedures
where for
example
um the uh you don't feel comfortable
saying anything unless it's the Chief
Justice who's saying
it fine then you're not going to say
anything and that is his loss and your
loss and that's my lecture for the
morning and I'm going to recognize the
chair would the weighted case study
address some or all of Madam chair's
concerns the weighted case load will
tell you specifically what we need for
judicial and staff resources when I say
staff I'm talking Heather's definition
of Staff um the worker bees in the
courts it also um I'm not sure that the
national Center had dealt with the
notion of Staff attorneys as opposed to
law clerks before so it's not really
clear on that but I'll just want to take
two minutes to explain the difference
and why we go staff attorney versus law
cler law cler and to me which is the
Supreme and Superior Court model uh
basically uh fresh generally fresh out
of Law School
uh lawyers who do a two-year
rotation assist in research and writing
and then hopefully go on and get a good
job in a firm and then a new crop comes
in we have figured out in the circuit
court that it's better to have permanent
positions because I believe that law
clerks are probably Reinventing the
wheel every time a new crop comes in you
have a motor vehicle stop with a fourth
amendment search issue write me the
order that order has been written a 100
200 300 times in the Superior Court we
have an orders Bank we have that order
in our orders Bank the staff attorney
can get that out and get it to the judge
without redoing the research so we don't
need as many because I think we've
created some efficiencies but we don't
have enough so I won't squander the
opportunity we would like uh additional
staff attorney resources I think the
judges would welcome it particularly in
the Family Division there's a lot of
legal nuances to Parenting and uh
marital cases the orders tend to be long
um an order needs to be clear when it
goes up to the Supreme Court so that the
Supreme Court has a a good record I'll
mention the court monitor issue just for
one reason I know the committee heard
um testimony that the judges somehow
have control over the the court
recording equipment I don't I don't know
how to turn the recording equipment on
or off I know there's a digital readout
on my bench that tells me that it's
running um we typically don't have
anybody sitting with the record in some
quotes the courot security officer
literally turns it on and turns it off
in the conquered Probate Court where I'm
now sitting a couple days a week there's
not a staff person person to go in there
I think we're going to turn the record
on in the morning and it's going to run
all day whether there's anyone in the
courtroom or not because we don't have
the staff to be in the courtroom we'll
have to put up a sign to say hey
recording in process so if you're in the
courtroom be be careful what you say
about the judge or the person on the
other side of your case Court monitors
are great they sit at the recording
equipment they make contemporaneous
notes if there are spelling issues that
come up in the trial they can that can
go with the record to the company that
types up the transcript when you get a
transcript prepared out of the Circuit
Court there are no contemporaneous notes
the record's the record we've had trials
where the judge thought the record was
running and at the end there's an appeal
and lo and behold there's no record
because there's something there was
something wrong with the equipment if
you go to Superior Court you'll see
somebody at the recording equipment with
headphones on listening in real time to
make sure all the microphones are
working and it it gives you a much
better record but that was the 20078 N
budget we basically eliminated our court
monitor positions in favor of Court
assistance because we were trying to be
frugal with the budget followup uh
followup is uh would it be appropriate
to ask um your office
to add to your sending us the weighted
case thing with a one or two pager
articulating this in other words if some
of us are going to Lobby our friends who
are working on the next budget the
weighted case study thing will be
helpful but so will a one or two pager
adding on to it the specifics that
you've articulated would it be
appropriate to ask you for that I would
be happy to work on that with folks from
the AOC and the Supreme Court and send
something over to the committee if
that's something that you would want
again understanding that we're talking
about the the next budget cycle that
right we'll be working on soon right I
do want to be clear that while um my
colleague used the word lobbying he
really didn't mean lobbying he meant
working with our colleagues to give them
the information necessary for them to
make an informed decision I yield to
what she
said understood every word has specific
meanings I know especially in this
building and Court monitor meant
something entirely different from what I
thought it meant and I've never met a
lobbyist in a Lobby I've only met them
in a corridor that's a discussion for
another day at least not in the local
bar your kind of bar not the other kind
of
bar anything else one additional piece
that isn't captured in the weighted case
load because it's really a measure of
how many court staff and judges are are
needed to handle the cas load itself um
is it doesn't capture a training
professional or or it it captures
training time for those folks who are
doing case load work um but the time of
a trainer isn't captured in that
weighted case load and so um so that's
not something that would be reflected in
that in that report that you'll see uh
we do have one full-time dedicated uh
Circuit Court staff person that's
dedicated to staff training um and she's
exceptional she has certification from
National Center for state courts on
education development um and that is a
substantial task for one person uh we
have about
390 staff in the Circuit Court
uh to be responsible for all of their
training and so uh if there were
additional resources available I think
uh deploying some of those to create
more of a training department uh or at
least provide her some additional
resources staff or time uh to work on
materials develop new curricula Etc
would be
helpful did you just raise your hand
please um to further to clarify further
um the bill as amended it's 475 or 499
it's one or the other um in terms of the
judge noting the reason for ruling it is
only to objections to evidence being
offered it's not to any other objection
that's a narrowly
construed
ask that's pretty much a trial right
okay a trial is about evidence um so
that pretty much would cover everything
from you may proceed to uh case
submitted everything in
between okay okay thank you thank you I
am conscious of how many cases are not
being heard because you're sitting here
and I you know and I worry about that
and I worry about your colleagues who
have a lot of work is there anything
else that you would like to share with
us any of you would like to share with
us I think the only other question that
was in your email that we haven't talked
about and it it's probably a quick uh
hit is the notion of Judges conferring
with each other about
maybe separate issues ongoing in the
same family so you've got it's not
uncommon to have an abuse neglect case a
criminal case maybe a landlord tenant
case a guardianship I mean there can be
a whole host of different cases
involving one family going on at the
same time hopefully they're all in the
same jurisdiction but they might not be
they might be on a on the line of you
know they live in this jurisdiction but
the kids are here because of placement
issues the code of judicial conduct
really prevents judges from conferring
with each other about cases what we have
tried to do in a limited area when a new
guardianship or I think abuse neglect
petition comes in we have added language
that says that the petitioner
understands that the court or staff will
uh May refer to other related cases and
in our case management system if there's
a abuse neglect case going and there's a
guardianship case there should be a
cross reference in the case management
system so the judge or staff knows that
there's a related case we try to make
sure that the same judge has both cases
to the extent we possibly can um I'm not
sure if that's responsive to the issue
that you asked but it's not perfect we
can't do it in every situation but
that's the best case scenario well I
think it is responsive and I thank you
and um uh of course you're much younger
than I am but I hope by now you realize
that the world was not perfect we're
just trying to get to be more perfect
than we are now um this subcommittee is
going to um kind of try to write up
where we are and um at some point in the
next few months but not immediately uh
because of the other responsibilities we
have in our committees um the full
committee will be called together by the
chair of the full committee uh
representative Pearson and um we will
try to
finalize the suggestions from the Myriad
subcommittees um so
um while we don't anticipate at this
moment call calling this subcommittee
together again if you have anything you
want to add or suggest or help inform us
um we would very much appreciate it and
um I hope that this report will be one
that is not just a report that serves to
permit people to vent
which is a helpful thing
um uh but also to help make sure that
you all can do a better job at what
you're doing and we thank you for for
that and we thank you also today for
taking the time to recognize that what
goes on in the Family Court differs
dramat
dramatically from what goes on really in
in the Circuit Court as a whole
the superior court and of course the
Supreme Court um so that to the extent
that decisions are made
generally for the judicial branch we
have to recognize the
differences within the judicial branch
or
we're not doing the right thing I think
it's no coincidence that tonight is the
season opener of Law and Order so I will
be there with an adult beverage looking
at Sam Waterson okay and I encourage all
my colleagues to do the same if they're
not
writing
decisions thank you very much for your
time we really appreciate it thank you
very much we appreciate this and all of
you for coming um this is difficult and
nobody nobody thinks what we're trying
to do is easy but we do look back at
legislative attempts in the past
um that might have met needs at that
time but we saw that at somewhat
different challenge this
time thank you just for public
information my desire as uh the um uh
chair of this subcommittee pointed out
when this subcommittee is finished up
our work and the other one that
representative katab heads does we will
will have a committee of the whole uh we
will review the final two reports we
will tweak them we will um finalize our
views on them I've decided not to shut
down the special committee I've pulled
the
membership um there's a few other issues
that we think need to be addressed but
we know some of them are being addressed
by legislation we're considering
presently others have various committees
or commissions around the state looking
at those issues and we did not see the
need to have yet another group doing the
same work but we can't always predict
the future so if in June something pops
up having to do with family court that
none of us has
anticipated we can then reactivate the
committee if we choose to other than
that we will just let it stay on hold
until it sunsets the 1st of November so
there is an outside possibility we may
crank up again but we don't know that so
just for the record thank you if we can
help in any way please let us know
appreciate that
sir
sorry